[APPLAUSE]
NAOMI NOVIK: Actually, I wanted
to steal this opportunity
to talk a little bit about the
kind of writing on a higher
level that I'm trying to do.
Because, in fact,
it's interesting.
One of the things
that I've had to do,
that I've been
doing for promotion,
is you end up
writing blog posts.
You go on sort of
blog tours now.
And it's funny
because I normally
don't like to write nonfiction.
I tend to prefer to put all my
thoughts and all my feelings
and let them kind of get
processed unconsciously
and just come out in fiction.
But when you start to try
to write about your process,
about what you're doing,
about writing in general,
sometimes you have to nail
down some of your thinking.
And I found that
I've been doing that.
And I sort of want
to talk about it
a little bit because I
think there's something--
I do think that there's a kind
of movement happening right
now, where for the last--
for a long time, really,
there's been a certain kind
of model of authorship.
A kind of top-down
model, basically.
The relationship between the
creator and the audience.
And that has been
changing drastically just
because it's become much
easier to be a creator.
The tools of creation in
various kinds of media
have become more accessible.
And the ability to
talk back to creators
has been changing
because of social media
networks and the accessibility.
The way that basically
makes it much easier
to have relationships
between one and many.
So what I wanted
to talk about is
how that can change what
it is that you're trying
to accomplish as a creator.
How that different
relationship with your audience
changes what you're
doing and how
that can come out
differently in your fiction.
Obviously, for a long time
the process of creation
was you sit in a room,
you make something.
Especially as an author, you
really do sit alone in a room.
And even now that's true.
And you make something and
you put it out to an audience,
who, if they talk back about it,
they generally are sort of talk
amongst themselves.
You don't necessarily hear back.
You might get a letter from
a fan every once in awhile.
If it's even bigger,
if it's something
like you're making a movie,
your audience essentially
has almost no way
to respond to you
except by how many
tickets sales there
are on the opening weekend.
And so these boundaries are
getting broken a lot right now.
And this happens obviously
in software as well.
In a previous life,
I was a programmer
and still do it for fun now.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about that as well.
But basically all those feature
requests, and feedbacks,
and feedback, and bug
reports-- and the problem
is that it's very hard to
respond to all of that.
Trying to form a
relationship on the basis
of replying to every sort
of individual comment
is very hard.
And people generally don't like
to do it, especially people who
are creating things.
You don't want to
interrupt the flow
of being able to either write
something or coding something.
I'm sure everybody here has
been in lots of meetings.
And doesn't like the way that
they break up the work day.
And so I sort of want-- and
that doesn't necessarily
align with the creator's goals.
Creators obviously have
various different goals.
But I sort of
would simplify them
to say that creators want to
either make art or software,
make a product, do good work.
That's one intrinsic goal.
They like to get praised.
And they like to get paid.
So those are some very, very
obvious, very basic things.
But I'm interested
in what happens
when you kind of change some of
those goals, sometimes subtly.
And when you get past that kind
of limited relationship, even
a relationship where the
audience is talking back
to the creator, to a different
kind of relationship that's
not necessarily visible in
a lot of mainstream media.
So about me, first, where
this all comes from.
So I've been writing
full time since 2004.
But my background, actually, to
sort of go back even further.
When I went to college,
I was an English major.
And I was going to
be a journalist.
Specifically, I was
going to be Lois Lane.
And sadly, I did an
internship and did
a lot of newspaper
writing and discovered
that Superman comics
are not necessarily
the most accurate depiction
of a journalistic career.
And after that, I did
actually squeak out
of college with
my English degree.
But in fact, what I spent my
senior year doing was MUSHing.
I don't know-- has anybody
here heard of MUSHes?
Yes, I see few.
So MUSH stands for Multi-User
Shared Hallucination.
And anybody who's played either
tabletop role-playing games
like D&D, or has played
an Infocom game, or a text
adventure game-- you're are in
a maze of twisty little passages
all alike kind of thing--
you've had that experience.
Except MUSHes are built,
generally, they're
text-only games.
They are built by
the participants
who then use them as a setting
for role-playing games.
And I actually learned to code
in the internal programming
language of MUSHes, which
was called MUSHcode.
And that is in fact, descriptive
of the way the code looks.
And basically since
then, I've sort of
oscillated between
programming and writing.
I decided I wanted-- I
decided this was great,
I wanted to work
on computer games.
So with an English
degree, it's kind of
hard to get a job working
on computer games.
So I was working and
working at the same time
on a graduate degree
in computer science.
And while I was doing that, I
was also writing as a hobby.
I was writing fan fiction.
I started doing that,
basically in 1995.
I discovered-- this was
actually even before, in 1994.
So this was before Mosaic
for the first web browser.
I discovered the
VAX/VMS at Brown.
And got onto the Star
Trek-L mailing list.
Yes, I see a few people,
a few people, yay.
And I started writing
Next Generation fan
fiction because there were
other people doing that.
And I thought this was great.
This was just this
wonderful experience.
And nobody was
getting paid for it.
For anybody who doesn't
know what fan fiction is,
it's basically you take
typically a TV series
or a movie or a book
and you write stories
about the characters and
settings, set in that universe.
And you're generally
doing it non-commercially.
You're not doing it
to try and sell it.
People obviously do write
those kinds of stories
commercially as tie-in novels.
But that's actually
tends to be quite far
away from what fan fiction is.
And people write these
stories just for love
and post them and share
them with one another.
And it becomes part of building
a community, basically around
this kind of work.
So, yes, while I was working
on my computer science degree
professionally, I was writing
fan fiction as a hobby.
And then I actually
had the chance
to work on a computer game.
I got a chance to work
on "Neverwinter Nights"
expansion set, "Shadows
Of Undrentide."
And I discovered that working
in crunch mode for six
months at a time was also
not quite as much fun
as it might have sounded.
And basically I came
out of that process.
I had the exciting
opportunity on that game.
When you have a really small
team working on something,
you get to be a little
more jack-of-all-trades.
So I actually had come
onto the expansion set team
as a programmer.
But they also needed
help with the design,
so I actually got to do
designing slash programming.
And I got to participate
in the process
of designing an entire computer
game, 30 hours of game play.
And the work of
structuring that and then
writing-- figuring out how
all the sort of side plots
and how you going to let
readers, I say readers,
but of course, it's players.
How you're going to let
players have meaningful impact
on the universe, despite
the fact that in some ways
you have to kind of bring
it back to key points.
So that the limited number
of cinematics and the budget
can all make sense.
No matter whether you're playing
like the evil player who's
out to conquer the
entire universe,
or the noble paladin who's
there to save everybody and be
a good guy.
And I came out of that
process and realized,
all right, I don't actually
want to move to Edmonton
and work 100 hours a week
for the rest of my life.
What am I going to do now?
And a good friend of
mine said why don't you
try writing a novel?
And I did and it was terrible.
It was like 20,000
words and I junked it
after struggling
to make it work.
And then about a
couple months later,
I saw the movie
"Master and Commander,
The Far Side Of
The World," which
was based on the Aubrey-Maturin
books by Patrick O'Brian.
And shortly afterwards I came
out of that-- that was awesome,
what could make it better?
Dragons.
So that was basically the
start of the Temeraire series.
Things like how could I make
the "Age Of Sail" even more
awesome?
And clearly, it's throw
some dragons in there.
And the thing is, of course,
that is actually very much
a kind of fan fiction move.
It is an impulse.
Fan fiction is the
impulse to want
more but a little different.
More, but from this perspective.
More of this, but I
want these characters
to have relationship.
More, but I want to see inside
that character's head who's
actually the bad guy.
And that kind of impulse,
through fan fiction,
also lends itself to more
of that, but with dragons.
More of that, but how about
if they were in space.
And that kind of
play is really quite
key to the sort of fanfic kind
of aesthetic, I would say.
So that was in
2004 that I started
writing the Temeraire series.
And in 2007,
because I got bored,
I started a nonprofit
organization
called The Organization
For Transformative Works.
And this was born out
of some frustration
in that a lot of us in the fan
fiction and sort of the broader
fan works community, saw--
there was a company specifically
then, called FanLib,
that basically was trying
to create a fan fiction
archive that they
were going to monetize.
And they were inviting
fan fiction writers
to come and post on their site.
And they were
saying things like,
we'll put you in touch with the
creators, we'll run contests,
and here, by the way, read
these terms of service
where you indemnify us
in case you ever get sued
for copyright and infringement.
And that'll be your
problem, not ours.
And so many of us were
quite up in arms about this.
And I made the
mistake of writing
a long post about how we
needed an archive of our own.
How we needed a home for
fan fiction and fanworks
that was like fan
fiction itself,
done in a non-commercial
way, that basically
supported preserving fan
works for the long term.
Which is another major issue.
When you have
non-commercial things,
there's nobody kind of
paying to keep the lights on.
And so a lot of
times, fan fiction
literally just--
enormous swaths of it
just vanish into thin air.
Obviously, I'm sure
many people here
remember the days of GeoCities.
Well, a lot of people hosted to
their fan fiction on GeoCities.
And a lot of those people,
after they posted their stories,
they left their sites
up but they went away.
And when GeoCities went
down, it just was gone.
Just disappeared.
A lot of that work.
Because a lot of them
had carefully made sure
their work was not
indexable, not archivable
by the archive.org crawlers.
They were anxious about
their work being taken down.
And they didn't necessarily
value their work.
They didn't necessarily value
their work because, of course,
there was no price tag on it.
And yet those stories were
extremely valuable to people
within the community.
So among that, we basically,
within this community,
we decided to build
ourselves an archive.
The archive of our
own was started--
went into beta in 2008.
It now has 1.5 million works
on it, more than 500,000 users.
We get 90 million
page views a week
from about more than eight
million unique visitors.
And this was done with
literally no advertising.
There's no paid
staff whatsoever.
There have been a total,
over the entire lifetime
of the project, of three
volunteer professional systems
administrators.
Usually one at a time.
There have been,
I think, a total
of four professional
coders, if you count me
as a professional coder,
which I actually was not
during this time period.
Everyone else, basically, who
has worked on this project
was an amateur.
Some people who worked
on it literally had never
written a line of code before.
Most of the people
who are our QA team
are complete newbies
when they come in.
The support staff is
basically just all volunteers.
And they respond to literally
every support inquiry,
to every question that they get.
And this whole
team is 95% female.
It is, as far as I know,
the largest open source
project-- female-run
open source project.
And it is not just an open
source piece of software.
It's an actual site
that's being maintained
under so many people.
And basically, I'm talking
about these various pieces
in my experience
because they all
come out of the kind of
creator-audience relationship
that I want to discuss.
A different kind of
creator-audience relationship.
And the things that come out--
the changes that come out
of that relationship, I find,
apply both to my writing
and to the software
that I've worked on.
And not just that
I've worked on,
but there are many--
there have always been
fan fiction writers who go pro.
That process is
accelerating, especially
now with self-publishing
becoming much easier.
One of the barriers to entering
publishing for a lot of writers
was this sort of
not wanting to go
through the process
of rejection.
Not wanting to go through
the process of gatekeeping.
And now a lot of
people-- and not
having the time to write an
entire kind of novel on spec.
And a lot of people
are now moving
to writing
professionally, to writing
original fiction, who were only
previously writing fan fiction.
But are bringing that kind
of aesthetic with them.
So I kind of wanted to
talk about it because I
think it's interesting.
And also, quite frankly, I do
feel a bit activist about this.
In that I would love to
see more of the fiction
that I read and more of
the software that I use.
And more of the media
that I consume generally
come from this place that
I want to talk about.
So specifically, I talked
about how fan fiction,
you can't sell it.
And so it creates a
gift economy where
those three goals that I
talked about for creators,
making good art, getting
praise, getting paid.
Where the getting paid
part apparently disappears.
Except it does not
actually disappear.
People are getting paid, but
they're getting paid in barter.
So in fan fiction, the reason
you would write a fanfic story
is because you want that more.
You want more.
More, but different.
And so the problem is
that if you want more,
you can't generally write fast
enough to satisfy yourself.
And so what you
really want is you
want other people to
write stories for you,
in exchange for the story
that you wrote for them.
And that actually
kind of creates
a different kind of relationship
and a different kind
of incentive for writers.
Sometimes this actually
becomes-- the sort of exchange
becomes explicit.
Where I run a challenge called
the-- I used to run, actually.
I finally retired last
year, very happily.
A challenge called the
Yuletide challenge,
which basically, every
holiday season, about 2000
people sign up.
And they get randomly assigned.
They sign up for
something between-- they
say I'll write a story at
any one of these six fandoms.
And I want a story in any
one of these four fandoms.
And we match them up.
And basically, each
person gets kind
of assigned as a Secret
Santa for somebody else.
So you're writing
a story for someone
who you may not even know.
And that person is writing
a story for someone
else that they
may not even know.
And meanwhile, someone's
writing a story for you.
And this giant exchange
happens where everybody
is writing these stories.
And these are--
Yuletide is specifically
for rare and obscure fandoms.
So it's the fandoms
where you never
get to see a story in
your tiny little fandom.
I've gotten-- I'm
trying to think
what the mode-- and
people can submit,
can ask for the most obscure,
most bizarre, things.
I've seen-- there was a great
story a few years ago that
was, basically, texts
from cephalopods.
I don't know if any
of you have seen this.
It is basically a
story about an octopus
and a squid sending each
other iPhone text messages.
And somebody wanted
that for yuletide.
Because they had seen
a video of an octopus.
I think it was that nopetopus.
Do you know the one
I'm talking about?
It's the octopus that's
running across the screen,
it's going nope,
nope, nope, nope.
So basically this
kind of exchange
can happen explicitly
in that model.
But it also is happening
informally all the time.
In that the goals for--
people basically want
more of those stories.
I just recently--
just the other week--
I literally watched
someone read through-- I
have 13 Captain America
fanfic stories posted.
A total of about 80,000 words.
And literally, within
the space of four hours,
I got 13 comments.
Because this person
was reading each story,
leaving a comment very nicely.
Going to the next
story, reading it.
And just kind of binge-- you
know it's Netflix watching.
It's binge watching,
except with fanfic.
And you get through
it too quickly.
And you want more.
And how do you get more?
You get more by basically
building a community
around your fandom.
You get more by
building a community,
not just around your fandom but
about the specific characters,
or the specific pairing.
People do a lot of
shipping in fandom.
You get people to write you
stories that are not just-- you
don't just want
people to write you
stories in a particular
fandom, necessarily.
You want them to write the
kind of stories you want.
And so you want-- so obviously
this changes the relationship
between the creator
and the audience
in some interesting ways.
First of all, obviously,
it changes status.
Right?
So we're all kind of little
hierarchical animals.
And normally, there's that
kind of geek hierarchy
where if you're the
science fiction writer,
you're on a higher
level of the hierarchy.
But in fandom that doesn't--
in fanfic that doesn't happen.
Because you are
writing for people
that you know are-- you're
hoping are going to write you
something back.
So you are kind of
writing to your peers.
You're writing to people
who are in it with you
I'm trying to court them.
You're specifically trying to
invoke their own creativity.
You really want to inspire
people to write more.
You really want
them to sort of feel
like-- you want them to
maybe not write more.
You would love somebody.
There's nothing that fanfic
writers love more than
when somebody makes a piece
of fan art for their story.
And fan art artists love it when
writers then take their artwork
and write a story based on it.
And that kind of free
interplay is something
that people are constantly
trying to generate.
You also want people to be
encouraged to leave comments,
to talk.
Because those comments-- the
more commenting is going on
in a fandom, the
more likely it is
that somebody else is going
to want to jump in and write
their own stories.
Because they know they're
going to get a lot of feedback.
And often, there's
one other piece,
which is that often
you're trying to convince
the audience of your take.
So I don't know how
many of you have ever
heard of the massive,
massive flame wars that
went on in Harry Potter fandom.
Between Harry, Ginny,
Harry, Hermione.
People literally wanted to kill
each other over this stuff.
And you think, why do you care?
Why are you having
these incredible battles
over this stuff?
And of course, it's
because there is actually
a finite resource being
competed for, to some extent.
You were literally trying
to get the good writers.
You want the good writers,
you want all the writers
to kind of come to
your side of the force.
You want them to come
and play with you
and write the stories
that you really want.
And how dare they go and
write that other pairing.
And people really
feel that-- and even
the rational among us who
recognize that the heart wants
what it wants and you can't
make people love something
and you have to just sort
of enjoy everything that's
being created-- you
still feel that when
fanfic writer that
you love starts
writing in a pairing
that isn't your pairing.
You always feel that, oh.
That "oh" moment,
where you're like,
ah, I wish they'd written
that story for me.
And actually, interestingly,
one of the things
that people frequently criticize
fan fiction about-- for,
is the quality.
People are like, ugh,
fan fiction is terrible.
People have stopped saying
that so much, at least to me.
Possibly because I talk
about fan fiction a lot,
so they're scared
to say it to me now.
But people would often
talk about the problems
with fan fiction.
And I mean, as we've seen,
thanks to Kindle Direct
Publishing, it's not
about fan fiction.
It's about the lack
of gatekeeping.
You know, Sturgeon's Law
acts very powerfully.
But for instance, I have seen
a lot of people talk about,
for instance, "Fifty
Shades Of Gray,"--
which started life
as fan fiction--
about how it's so bad.
And they talk about it
and I know many people
who are just confused.
They feel like
they don't like it.
They look at the
text and it's not
even that it's not for them.
It's just like it seems
like it's badly written.
But one of the
interesting things
is that bad fan
fiction actually can
serve some of the function
of some of those goals.
Fan fiction does
not necessarily have
to be great or even good to
help produce a community.
In fact, I know
many people who were
motivated by bad fan fiction.
Somebody writes a
bad fanfic story.
And that gets them mad.
And they're like, this
story-- that idea is good,
but they did so badly.
I'm going to write it again.
Or they read the story, it's
like the characters would never
behave that way.
It's terrible.
I'm going to write it again.
And frankly, just
having people talking,
it's like the power
of having somebody
talking in a room breaking
the ice, in a way.
And kind of making
somebody else feel
like, well, I could write a
story as good as that one.
Or I could write a
story better than that.
And so I'm going to try.
Actually has some
of those community
building effects, whether
or not the actual work
itself is necessarily
brilliantly written.
But, of course,
good fan fiction,
really well-written fan fiction
is trying to do something,
is also trying to
accomplish those same goals.
It's trying to
make the good art,
and it's trying to be praised.
The fan fiction writers
love comments and feedback
since that's the
only-- that's sort
of the immediate direct
reward that they get for it.
But they are also
trying to get--
it is trying to be seductive.
It is trying really
actively to give pleasure.
And it's trying to
give pleasure of a kind
that you want
mirrored back to you.
Generally, you write
the kinds of stories
that you want to read in fandom.
And the way that differs from
the kind of more mainstream
model, the more common
model, is that a lot of times
that is only performative.
A lot of times you're
writing a book,
you want your book to
completely stand out.
You don't want your
book to be like anything
that anybody else has written.
You want your book--
you want people to say,
that's an original
work of genius.
You want people to say, I've
never seen anything like that
before.
You want people to
say-- you want to have--
and frequently you want to have
a kind of controlling effect
on the reader's experience.
That's kind of the model that's
a lot of times-- it's sort
of that film director thing.
Sit in this theater, turn
off your cell phones,
you're going to experience my
vision for the next two hours.
And you're going to like it.
And that's really sort of the
antithesis of the fan fiction
kind of approach where you
really want-- you're like,
here, look at this thing.
Don't you want to
come and don't you
want to start talking
with me about it?
Don't you want to make
something just like this?
A lot of times you get
that in books as well.
Authors are trying
to cause the reader
to really have an
experience that they're
trying to push on the reader.
And it's not necessarily
what they almost
think the reader wants.
It's like they want to perform.
They want to show off.
They want to show their skill.
They want to convince you
that they're great writers.
that this is a great story.
They aren't always necessarily
thinking about giving pleasure.
They aren't always
necessarily thinking
about making you really
just deeply entertained.
And so specifically,
like the grimdark genre,
which I feel like has been
really dominant for a long time
now-- and we've seen it largely
because they're obviously--
there are kind of cultural
influences on this.
So HBO has produced "Game
Of Thrones," "Sopranos."
And a lot of cable television
has this sort of incentive
where the way they differentiate
themselves from networks
is they can have more
violence and more sex.
And generally what they do is
they have a lot more violence.
They have a lot of
sexual violence.
And they have some more
sex, but they still
are quite leery of getting
categorized as pornographic,
so very often the
sex is not super fun.
And so the grimdark
genre broadly
is kind of like convincing
the reader to believe
in the universe you've made.
And convince them and let them
sort of suspend their disbelief
by being like, this universe
just sucks so horribly.
Look at all these
terrible things.
And sort of putting
one unpleasant
experience after another
to kind of create
this feeling that it's not sort
of a shiny plastic universe.
And we all get a lot of
shiny plastic universes
from Hollywood.
And not super exciting books.
And we don't generally
want the super plastic.
And grimdark was
kind of a reaction
to something coming before it.
But at the same time,
that kind of mentality,
that kind of knowing that
this universe that you're in,
as a reader, as a
consumer, is terrible,
can be kind of deadening.
You're kind of scared to like
anybody on "Game Of Thrones."
Because you know the
chances are really terrible
shit's going to happen to them.
Sorry.
And it's hard to care about
Batman when you actually
accept that Gotham is
just totally irredeemable
and is going to stay terrible
no matter what he does
and that everything
is just awful
and nobody there
deserves to be saved.
And then, finally, you're
like, why do I care about that?
And why am I watching this?
And I was just watching
"Princess Bride"
with my child the other day.
It's like, why are you
reading me this for?
And I frequently feel
that way sometimes.
So what I think of as the
fan fiction, or possibly,
more broadly, I should call
it the optimistic literary
aesthetic, what it's
trying to do instead,
is it's not necessarily trying
to tell you a happy story.
It's not trying to tell
you a plastic story,
a sanitized story, where
everything works out great.
And nothing ever bad happens.
And everybody survives and they
all lived happily ever after.
Because that's not pleasurable.
But it is trying to
give you a really deeply
pleasurable experience where
you feel like the author's kind
of in the trenches with you.
The author is like, this is an
experience that I want to have
and I'd like you to
come along with me.
And that feeling-- when you get
that feeling that the author is
in the trenches with you,
in that way, in that sort
of intimate way where they're
trying to sell you something
that they would like
to buy themselves,
is that it allows you
to have a kind of trust.
If you believe that an author
really is deeply invested
in a particular
character, really loves
a particular character and
feels for that character
the same way that they're
trying to make you, the reader,
care about that
character, then you
don't know-- that doesn't
tell you that character is not
going to die.
But it does tell you
that that character's not
going to die in an
unsatisfying, empty way.
If that character
dies, it is not
going to be for an effect
in the larger universe,
it's going to be because
it is a meaningful part
of that character's story.
And that trust, knowing
that, allows you
to kind of lower your barriers.
Especially in fan fiction, a
lot of fan fiction readers--
there's a lot of trigger
warnings in fan fiction
that people try to
put on their work.
People generally
specifically try
to alert people for any
kind of graphic violence
or sexual violence.
There's a lot of-- fan
fiction is very heavily
female-dominated.
There are a lot of victims
of sexual assaults in it.
And there are many people who
both either want to avoid it
completely, or actively want.
Like rape fiction is actually
a huge genre in fan fiction
where people frequently
are working through issues
that they have had.
And at the same time,
it's all kind of labeled,
so that people go
through it, go into it
knowing what they're getting.
And knowing the experience
that they're going to have.
And that the writer
is in it with them
and is having the
experience with them.
And that means that-- actually,
this doesn't stop, in fact.
This effect of this
audience change
doesn't stop at just writing.
Fan fiction also has basically--
in the fan fiction community,
the function of editing is
taken over by beta readers.
In professional
publishing, I actually
been very lucky in that
I've had two, now multiple,
long-term relationships
with editors.
But a lot of editors
are essentially in a job
for like a year, and
then they're gone.
They moved to a
different company,
they moved to a
different position,
they have different authors.
And you don't have an
incentive to create
a long-term relationship.
And very frequently
there is a process
that happens, where the
author's first book comes in.
They get lots of attention.
They've worked on
it for 10 years.
It goes out and
it's a big success.
And the second one, they
just want it on time.
They just want it on deadline,
they want it to schedule.
And very little editing gets
done on the second book,
the third book.
In fact, all of my work gets
edited by my fan fiction
beta readers before
my editor sees it.
And my fan fiction beta
readers are a lot tougher
than my editor.
And my editor is very good,
but my fangirls are brutal.
And that's partly
because, again,
just like with the writing, beta
readers in fandom, in fanfic,
are starting from
the same place.
They're actually
peers with the author.
It's not a kind of
subordinate relationship.
They are peers because
they are invested.
They're both starting from
the same place of being
invested in the fandom.
Being invested in the
characters and the universe
that they're working from, and
feeling equally authoritative.
If you're beta reading
a fan fiction story,
you can say, well, no, Captain
Kirk would not do that.
And you have as
much right to say
that as the author
of the story does.
Obviously, when you're
doing it with original work,
it's harder.
First of all, it's harder
to get your beta readers
to get an editor invested in
an original world the same way
that somebody is invested in
an original wor-- in the world
of a show or
television or movie,
whatever, that they already
love themselves independently.
But it can be done.
And when you get somebody
who's willing to invest
that way in your original work,
who will tell you if it sucks,
who will tell you that they
think the characters that you
invented are acting in
an out-of-character way
in the story you
just wrote, that's
where you get the best work.
That's the kind of editing
that produces truly great work.
And basically, that's something
that happens so routinely
in fan fiction, that you almost
take it for granted as a fan
fiction writer.
Until you go to
professional publishing.
And suddenly, you're
getting such very nice notes
from your editor.
And they're like,
well, maybe you
might want to change the scene.
Meanwhile the beta reader's
like, he was terrible,
what were you thinking?
Destroy it completely,
burn it with fire.
But you get places
faster that way.
And frankly, this also
happens with software.
The archive was built--
the only incentive
that we possibly had to offer
people to come and spend
enormous amounts of free time
writing code for the archive
that they could be gainfully
paid for somewhere else,
was basically, that they
really wanted an archive.
So that they wouldn't have
their stories getting lost.
So that they could actually
go back and read and read
the stories.
Many of the people who've
coded, worked on the archive,
are themselves not
fan fiction writers.
But they read fan fiction.
They look at fan art.
They watch fan vids.
And this was, in fact,
their way of kind
of giving back to that
community, of participating
in the gift economy.
So as a result, of
course, the archive
actually has some features.
So for instance, it
has a complete set
of tools for running the kind
of gift exchange challenges
that I was talking about.
Even though that
isn't what you would--
if you were sitting down,
if you were doing it
as a professional
corporate thing.
And you wrote, what
are the 10 biggest
features that we need
for our archive, that
would not appear on the list.
That should not have
been, in a certain way,
part of the core functionality.
But in fact, it was extremely
important to have it
as part of the
core functionality
because it's what got
our coders working.
It's what brought
people to the table.
It's what brought people with
their skills to the table.
It's also meant that people
who run challenges in fandom
are frequently the
kinds of people
who have large communities
and lots of friends.
And so they came to
the archive because it
had much better tools.
And then they were like,
to all their friends,
all their networks, basically
like, come over here
and let's play over here and
put your stories on here.
And that's entirely how
the whole system built.
It also has, for
instance, a skin system
that essentially allows
you to completely,
if you know a little CSS, you
could essentially completely
redesign the entire front end
of the archive to your tastes.
One of the example skins was
pink, it had pandas on it.
And these are sort of cases of
things that don't necessarily
make sense.
But they were passionate.
They had real--
there was investment
visible in their
presence on the archive.
And that in fact, in turn,
changes the relationship
that the users have with
the archive in that people
who were using the archive
can see in many different ways
that this thing
was built by them.
Even if they individually
didn't participate.
Even if they don't know
anybody who's on the team.
When they send a
support request, when
they read the FAQ, and
the way it's written.
When they read the
terms of service
which are actually
human readable,
and talk specifically.
And have their own FAQ
that specifically addresses
things like, what do we do when
we get a DMCA takedown notice?
And the answer is not the
YouTube thing where we're like,
we're going to pull
it down automatically
with a system that doesn't
see it, actually look at it.
And that there's actually
somebody individually
looking at each instance.
And again, this creates trust
and that encourages investments
and lowering barriers
in a way that
is not the case where
you feel like you're just
being sold something.
Or where you feel like
you're being given something
by someone who's sort
of like, and here,
here, lower person down there.
I'm going to hand
you this thing.
It's a gift out of the
goodness of my heart.
And pay me money for it.
There does-- it does
create a different feeling.
And so, really,
what I would like
to make a case for, I
think, more broadly,
is just a sense of
letting-- trying
to have that mindset
when creating things.
Trying to sort of be in the
trenches with your audience.
And trying to be
part of it with them.
Try to have the
experience, even as you're
giving the experience.
And I think that establishing
that kind of trust
with the reader, with the
audience, for whatever it
is you're producing,
and I think that creates
a different kind of work.
I think it creates a
warmer kind of work,
a more generous kind of work.
And I would like
to see more of it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I was afraid that I was not
going to have enough material
and it turns out I've
talked quite a lot.
But I'm happy to take
a couple of questions
if anyone has them.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Have you ever used
critters.org and how
do you feel like that
maybe compares or contrasts
with the existing
kind of fanfic trading
stuff you were talking about?
NAOMI NOVIK: So
critters.org, I have used it.
It's basically a site
where you sign up
to critique other
people's original work.
And they give you critiques
of your work in return.
You sort of earn points, if
I'm remembering correctly.
And in fact, the
problem with critters,
and the problem with
most writing workshops,
is precisely that.
That it is quid pro quo.
And the problem is that you're
coming into it as a writer.
And while other writers can
be very good critiquers.
In fact, most of my
best beta readers
are themselves people
who write as well.
At the same time, when
you're doing it in order
to get feedback on
your own piece, that
is a completely different
motivation than what happens
in fanfic where
the motivation is,
I want that story you've
written to be as good as it
can possibly be for me.
Where you're coming in from a
mindset of, I really love this.
I love what you do and I
want to make it better.
With any kind of
writing workshop,
sometimes you can get lucky.
And I think that's when you
get really great work out
of writing workshops,
is where you have
a small group of people
in a-- sort of intimately,
who really like
each other's work.
And who really want
to all rise together.
Who are kind of doing, not
necessarily the same thing,
but adjacent enough things.
And like what each other
are doing well enough.
Because otherwise,
it's very hard.
One of the hardest
things about taking
feedback, one of
the hardest things
to learn, I think-- and I
don't feel like I learned this
until I had been writing
for maybe 15 years--
was how not to take feedback.
The feedback to
leave on the table.
And a lot of times
the problem is,
when somebody-- when you get
critiques from critters.org,
frequently you'll get
five or six critiques
that are all kind of pulling the
story in opposite directions.
Because they all want something
different from the story.
And so, as a result, I do think
that you get better editing
when you're being
edited by people
who want to read the story as
opposed to by people who want
critique on their own work.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: As a practical matter,
how much of an impediment
is copyright law to the
production of fan fiction?
NAOMI NOVIK: So copyright law
has the fair use exemption
here in this country.
And that could be an entire
separate talk on its own.
But it makes exemptions
for transformative,
not exemption specifically,
but there's a fair use test,
basically.
And some of the characteristics
that it looks at
are whether our work
is transformative.
And whether work
is non-commercial,
whether it's competing
in the market.
Obviously, the kind of fan
fiction that I'm talking about
is non-commercial.
It is being posted for free.
It's not competing
with the original work.
And in fact, generally,
you don't really
see fan fiction for something,
unless it's also just
like a hit.
Because you need a big
enough base of audience
for people who want
to write in that
fandom to find each
other in a way.
And so copyright law,
basically, there's
been a lot-- for a long time,
a lot of misunderstandings
about copyright law and
how it affects fan fiction.
And a lot of fan fiction writers
were sort of underground,
as a result. Or
would say-- there's
a default kneejerk thing of
people saying fan fiction's
illegal.
No, it's not.
And obviously, any one
individual piece, the fair use
defense is an
affirmative defense,
meaning you don't get
to tell-- you don't
get to know whether your
fan fiction story is
fair use, unless it actually--
unless you actually get sued
and go to court.
And first of all, nobody's
going to sue a fan fiction
writer because, why would you?
That's like, and
you're my biggest fan,
I'm going to sue you.
For putting out that free
advertising for my work.
How dare you?
And the fan fiction writer
is, I have no money.
So there's really
nothing, there's
nothing to sue them for.
And also, nobody's
really going to sue,
because nobody wants
to lose that case.
And one of the
thing the OTW does
is a lot of legal advocacy.
And basically, we
feel they would lose.
So that's what I can tell you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What do
you think of authors
who maintain more
direct relationships
with their communities,
especially Brandon Sanderson.
NAOMI NOVIK: Who maintain
their own interactive community
with their readers, you mean?
Yeah, obviously, that's
one of the things that's
going on with social media
lowering the barriers,
lowering the distance.
And making communication
just easier, simply.
A lot of authors are doing that.
But I think it's related but
it's not exactly the same.
The work of connecting on a sort
of individual basis to people
also does form communities.
And it also has some
of that same work.
And I do think of
Brandon Sanderson
as a writer who was
also trying deeply
to entertain his audience.
I do think of him as
one of the writers who
wants you to have a
really great time when
you're reading his stuff.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Also [INAUDIBLE] where he
published all the drafts.
And then people would
view them on their own.
NAOMI NOVIK: Right.
And exactly, he's
inviting-- he is
trying to invite people to come
in and play in that same way.
So yes, it's absolutely--
but there are
two kind of separate things.
Like what I actually
kind of want
to talk about is more like
the literary aesthetic.
Like the mindset
of the actual work
that you produce when you're
having that kind of motivation,
which is separate
from a lot of writers.
A lot of creators don't have
the ability or the energy.
I mean, Brandon has
crazy amounts of energy.
I was on a panel recently
where we formed the theory
that every time he finishes a
book, he gets to clone himself.
And that's how he continues
to produce at this level.
But a lot of people just don't
have the cycles, basically.
The time to produce, to
interact on that level,
on a personal level.
And so what I'm kind
of interested in
is how you can, nevertheless,
put yourself in a mindset
as the writer, where you're
trying to experience,
where you're trying to make
work from that position.
Even if you're not
actually spending
a lot of time talking to your
direct audience one-on-one.
AUDIENCE: Also, what about fan
fiction, their own subfandoms?
Especially "Methods
of Rationality," which
has a number of [INAUDIBLE].
NAOMI NOVIK: What do you mean?
Like people who are writing
fan fiction of book universes?
AUDIENCE: Of other fans fiction.
"Methods of Rationality"
has at least five or six--
NAOMI NOVIK: Oh, sure.
No, that's all-- I mean, that's
been happening for a long time.
People write sequels
to each other's
fanfic constantly in fandom.
And in fact, one of the things
that the archive policies
specifically allow is
that there's actually
code in there for
listing another story
as the inspiration,
or as the basis
that you either remixed
it or you wrote a sequel
or something.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just wondering your thoughts
on other sites and platforms,
like fanfiction.net,
and what you've
learned from those other
sites and platforms
in building out AO3.
NAOMI NOVIK: So
fanfiction.net-- and actually,
are we out of time?
Is it OK if we keep going?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Last question.
NAOMI NOVIK: Last question, OK.
So fanfiction.net has been
around for years and years.
And I feel-- I have
a complicated set
of feelings about it.
First of all, it came
out of the community.
It was built long before
anybody had the idea that it
was going to make money.
The people who built it, built
it for basically their friends.
And so, I think of it
as a labor of-- as part
of this community in a way
that I didn't think of.
For instance, the
company FanLib--
that I talked about briefly--
that came in and was
going to do it from outside.
They basically just
looked at the Google ad
revenue of
fanfiction.net and were
like, oh, we want
a piece of that.
Even though they had literally
no connection to the community.
The problems with
fanfiction.net is now
they are advertiser-supported.
They are for profit.
And that has certain--
that has problems
that we've seen in general
with social media networks.
I mean, we all know this, right?
If you're not paying for it,
you're part of the product.
And so the way that
results, is, for instance,
you've got advertisers.
The advertiser's
like, oh, we don't
want any-- we don't want
that Harry-Draco NC-17 slash
on the archive, on the
fanfiction.net site.
And so periodically,
fanfiction.net
would go in and purge
enormous swaths of stories
and kick people off with
no warning, no chance
to save their work.
Similar things happened
on LiveJournal,
which was enormously
popular around the time
that we were
founding the archive.
And that, of course, is
terrible from the perspective
of somebody who wants to
preserve the entire community.
And really see the kind
of work that's being done.
And so that's why the archive
is-- we're really aggressively
protect the free speech rights.
We don't take any advertising.
It's like public
radio, basically.
We have a fundraising
drive twice a year.
And we ask people to support it.
And people have supported
it, more than enough
to continue it,
keeping it afloat.
But that's sort of the problem
with fanfiction.net I think
it's-- and for a long time.
And now Wattpad
similarly-- anything
that ultimately has
a for profit motive,
is not reliable when
what you're producing--
when you don't have--
where you don't
have the power of
an actual contract.
Where you don't have the
power, that your thing is not
making you money.
Your fan fiction is
not making you money.
And so you can't actually afford
to spend money on it, in a way.
You can't afford to
have a legal battle.
That's my general feeling.
That's why we made
the archive nonprofit.
The OTW is non-profit.
All right, thank
you so very much.
[APPLAUSE]